cdu corona debakel union so titel die
taz und tatsächlich könnte die masken
affäre zu einem wahl debakel am
kommenden sonntag in rheinland-pfalz und
baden-württemberg werden ermittlungen
wegen bestechlichkeit hohe provisionen
beim geschäft mit der pandemie und die
sorge dass noch mehr abgeordnete ihr amt
missbraucht haben könnten fraktions und
parteiführung wollen jetzt durchgreifen
versprechen aufklärung und für die
zukunft schärfere regeln für abgeordnete
was läuft da schief im parlament und wie
schaffen volksvertreter wieder vertrauen
die masken affäre das geschäft mit der
krise unser thema in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen anja mayer ist bei uns
politische korrespondentin für den
weser-kurier
zuvor war sie viele jahre bei der taz
schokolade klaus peter schmidt die
gelder erst kommunikationsberater hat
berufserfahrung im journalismus und in
der politik unter anderem als
staatssekretär der hessischen
landesregierung und auch als
langjähriger beratung berater des
bundesfinanzministeriums und des
kanzleramts zugeschaltet ist uns karl
jurka er ist freiberuflicher lobbyist in
berlin paris und wien schönen guten
abend nach wien in diesem moment hallo
yoga und dennis radtke ist bei uns von
der cdu er ist mitglied des europäischen
parlaments und auch des landesvorstands
der cdu in nordrhein westfalen und hat
kann sie direkt die erste frage es geht
ja um zwei abgeordnete den
csu-abgeordneten nüßlein gegen ihn wird
vom ermittelt wegen steuerhinterziehung
ist aus der partei ausgetreten
inzwischen markus liebl von der cdu hat
sein mandat niedergelegt er hat 250.000
euro für die vermittlung von masken
erhalten wenn sie jetzt ihre
parteikollegen nüßlein und löbel treffen
würden was würden sie denen sagen ja gut
hab das mal so was würde ich ihnen sagen
ich würde ihn fragen würde ihnen sagen
dass ich fassungslos bin und ich würde
sie fragen ob sie noch alle tassen im
schrank haben also ich meine in die
eigene tasche zu wirtschaften das
verbietet sich per se schon aber dass in
einer solchen situation in einer solchen
krisensituation zu tun wo unternehmen
und arbeitnehmer sich sorgen um ihre
existenz machen wo man im letzten jahr
wirklich eine akute not hatte wo
bekommen wir masken überhaupt das
nötigste zu machen den krankenhäusern
und pflegeheimen
das macht mehr verfassungs los und das
würde ihn auch so ins gesicht sagen
wie erklären sie sich dass die kommt
sowas dass jemand dann kein gespür mehr
dafür hat
wie soll man das sagen die war warum
sollte ausgerechnet der der typus des
empfängers mit klebrigen fingern
warum sollte ausgerechnet der aus der
gaußsche normalverteilung herausfallen
natürlich haben sie in jedem system egal
ob in politik in großen unternehmen in
verwaltung betreffen sie auch immer
wieder schwarze schafe also von na ja
das lässt sich mit dem menschlichen
naturell natürlich auch erklären
gleichwohl so etwas darf nicht passieren
und wie man ihr im laufe der sendung
vermutlich auch noch über strengere
regeln
genaueres hinschauen diskutieren das
anfang nicht akzeptabel und deswegen war
es auch richtig dass wir sofort einen
klaren schnitt gesetzt haben wer so
etwas macht der kann nicht für cdu und
csu verantwortung übernehmen egal an
welcher stelle
klare worte herr schmidt ihr geld sind
das jetzt neuer nüßlein und hebel sind
das schwarze schafe oder ist das deren
problem der cdu mann sagt ja das kann
immer wieder passieren im juni hatten
wir den fall am tor der etwas anders war
aber wo es auch um die frage der
persönlichen vorteilsnahme gegen also
ich fürchte das ist nicht nur ein fall
der cdu in dem fall sind schwarze schafe
wenn man im parteien bild bleibt aber es
gab ja in der vergangenheit der
bundesrepublik viele fälle die ähnlich
gelagert waren wo fdp-abgeordnete auch
spd-abgeordnete betroffen waren
wir haben noch drei fälle die anhängig
sind im bundestag zwei cdu ein
spd-abgeordneter die unter anklage
stehen unrechtmäßige dinge getan zu
haben sich bereichert zu haben
also das ist natürlich etwas mehr bei
den konservativen zu suchen
wahrscheinlich würde mich wundern wenn
ich auch noch ein fdp abgeordneter und
mindestens einer auftauchen wurde in der
liste die hier sparen jetzt vorlegen
will
aber es ist natürlich was der rat gesagt
ein unding
aus der not anderer ein geschäfts- und
machen noch dazu wenn man volksvertreter
ist und als solcher gewählt ist und das
ist ein vertrauensverlust und ein
schaden für die demokratie und für das
parlament das dringend dann auch
konsequenzen ziehen muss und die cdu
fraktion hat das jahr angekündigt aber
ich denke der gesamte bundestag bekommen
wir ja noch zu
muss nicht nur eure geblieben neue
regeln ganz wichtig herr jurga muss ein
abgeordneter aber nicht interessen ganz
klar und wir erinnern uns vor einem jahr
hatten wir alle das problem dass wir zu
wenig masken hatten kann man da nicht
sagen ja ein abgeordneter der muss doch
ganz klar die interessen auch der
wirtschaft wahrnehmen und schauen dass
und muss dann auch vermitteln dass das
in ordnung
da habe ich nicht dass das aufgabe des
abgeordneten ist die interessen der
wirtschaft wahrzunehmen
abgeordnete hat die interessen der
gesamten bevölkerung war zunehmend vom
theresa gewählt worden um die interessen
der wirtschaft wahrzunehmen gibt
verbände gibt es interessensvertreter
gibt jahr den furchtbaren berufsstand
von lobbyisten sowie milch gehört aber
das sollte eigentlich eine klare
trennung geben immerhin das ist vor 200
jahren schon erfunden worden lobbyist
der vorraum zum parlament um nicht das
parlament selber also der abgeordnete
der sich zum lobbyisten macht und
bestimmte firmen interessen wahrnimmt
ist also fehl am platz wie ich in berlin
gegangen habe ich auch schon eine weile
her hat mal gesagt na ja was ist der
wichtigste unterschied zwischen
deutschland und österreich
in deutschland ist es so wenn einer geld
verdienen will geht er in die wirtschaft
und in österreich geht einer der geld
verdienen will in die politik
das ändert sich jetzt hoffentlich und
das wird jetzt hoffentlich anders weil
in österreich jetzt doch einige
strafrechtlich verurteilt werden und
offenbar brauchen wir in deutschland
solche strafrechtlichen verurteilungen
auch also schärfere regeln damit das
geahndet wird frau meier das ist ja
jetzt ein heftiger vorwurf der da es
immer merkt auch dass da in der
unionsfraktion das eine ziemliche wuthe
sowie herr radke das ja auch gerade klar
formuliert hat was bedeutet das für die
cdu in dieser situation
naja für die cdu kommt es zur unzeit
sowieso also jeden skandal kommt immer
zur unzeit aber jetzt ist die zeit noch
verschärft wer hat wenige tage vor den
landtagswahlen sind in rheinland pfalz
und baden württemberg und im grunde die
spitzenkandidatin dieser beiden parteien
also der cdu wünschen können dann im
grunde ein pack jetzt also das wird
glaube ich nichts mehr
aber ich will das einfach auch noch mal
kurz sagen weil er ja gesagt hat in
deutschland wer geld verdienen wir so in
die wirtschaft gehen ich finde die
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestags
sind sehr gut bestellt und sie kriegen
eben deshalb auch höchstrichterlich
verbrieft so viel geld damit sie das
nämlich genau nicht tun müssen und wer
es tut begibt sich finde ich auf eine
moralische ebene diese ungefähr so auf
dem niveau wie die leute die in der
ersten welle in notaufnahmen die die
desinfektion spin.de abgeschraubt haben
also das ist so empörend was wir da
gerade erleben
und da ist ja das thema heirat schon
angesprochen vertrauen also der der
vertrauensverlust ist enorm in dieser
frage und ich finde ich auch ja die
waren jetzt sind wichtig aber es wird
glaube ich eine ganz langfristige
wirkung führt durchs ganze war ja jetzt
gehen also ein ganz starker
vertrauensverlust in die politik herr
radke was hören sie wenn sie mit
mitbürgern sprechen was ist so die die
reaktion oder auch mit anderen
wahlkämpfen die jetzt versuchen müssen
am wochenende für die cdu ja noch
wahlkampf zu machen für ihn rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg wo spüren
sie die auswirkungen da ja ganz gleich
mal die die stimmung ist natürlich
entsetzen lähmendes entsetzen
man darf nicht vergessen es sind ja auch
noch kommunalwahlen in hessen und
ich meine wir reden hier über tausende
von von männern und frauen die sich
ehrenamtlich in kommunalpolitischen
mandaten engagieren die werden jetzt in
ihrem wahlkampf mit diesen dingen
konfrontiert und werden natürlich mit
verhaftet obwohl sie damit überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun haben also der der
vertrauensverlust der der schaden der
ist einfach gigantisch und ich meine
frau meier ja am sonntag sind wahlen
aber auch wenn wir jetzt kein wahljahr
hätte man auch wenn wir dieses jahr
keine bundestagswahl hätten was da
geschehen ist ist absolut inakzeptabel
und deswegen sind jetzt die die
selbstreinigungskräfte auch in partei
und fraktion gefordert um da ganz
schnell reinen tisch zu machen um ganz
schnell die steinchen umzudrehen um
nämlich einst auch ganz klar zu
verhindern
das jetzt hier eine generelle
kriminalisierung von cdu und csu
stattfindet von von unionsabgeordneten
weil das ist nicht angemessen das ist
nicht sachgerecht und dagegen müssen wir
uns mit mit allen mitteln wehren also
die die sowas gemacht haben klar aus
unserer mitte weisen aber wir müssen uns
genauso gegen der generelle
kriminalisierung der union wäre aber es
soll jetzt ist da eben jetzt eine liste
geben wo dann geschaut wird welche
unternehmen welche abgeordnete haben
unternehmen geholfen nochmal deshalb die
frage ist gab im letzten jahr wirklich
ein problem mit zu dass wir zu wenig
machen hatte der schmächtige können sie
sich vorstellen dass dann abgeordnete
sagt ich guck mal open up in unternehmen
in meinem wahlkreis ist und kann das
vielleicht helfen ich finde das finde
ich ganz normal
und wenn er dann sagt hier
bundesgesundheitsminister oder
beschaffungsstelle der bundeswehr oder
das holz die ja alle versucht haben zu
beschaffen hier ist jemand da kann euch
das bieten kümmert euch darum oder nicht
wenn er genau gehabt und dann ist
schluss dann ist vorbei dann kriegt er
kein geld dann hat er auch kein recht
auf geld sondern er hat seine pflicht
getan dem unternehmen zu helfen und der
allgemeinheit zu helfen indem genug
masken gerade damals für die
intensivstation und so weiter
beschafft werden mussten das war ja
selbstverständlich dass man da hilft
wenn man kann aber das problem ist ja
dass also bin ich mir nicht mehr zu
gerne nicht dazu noch mal was sagen
also ich finde das ist sogar die
kernaufgabe von dem abgeordneten
jeder abgeordnete einige jahre im
geschäft ist verfügt über sehr gutes
netzwerk in politik und wirtschaft und
verbänden und sich dann sozusagen an
dieser stelle einzuschalten und zu sagen
ich hab dann trat ich kann da was machen
das ist für mich die kernaufgabe von dem
abgeordneten aber dafür darf dich doch
nicht die hand aufhalten sondern dafür
werde ich von den bürgerinnen und
bürgern gewählt ich mein ich setzen die
natürlich auch für für unternehmen für
verbände in meinem wahlkreis im
ruhrgebiet ein das ist mein job sonst
haben die leute den falschen mann
gewählt aber dafür bekomme ich geld und
zwar vom steuerzahler und nicht von
unternehmen oder interessensverbänden
aber wie kann das dann doch passieren er
yoga wollten sie da noch was zu sagen ja
ich wollte dazu was sagen weil ich nicht
verstehe dass dann ein abgeordnete gibt
es sind gottseidank wenige die meinen
sie kriegen dann geld dafür es ist die
verdammte pflicht und schuldigkeit des
abgeordneten wenn er wo politisch helfen
kann das zu tun weil er ist ja dazu da
das land zu besteigen
aber er ist nicht dazu da um bei einem
öffentlichen vergabe prozess zu sagen
ich vermittle die firma so besuch hin
und holen wir dann für diese firma
provision das gab es nicht geben das ist
nicht in ordnung dass gibt übrigens auch
in meiner branche nicht es gibt keine
erfolgsabhängigen honorare in der
politischen beratung weder für den
politiker noch für den berater sondern
jeder kriegt sein geld abgeordnete sein
gehalt vom deutschen steuerzahler wir
unseren stundensatz und das ist es aber
was hier so jetzt dargestellt wird als
übliche system das soll nicht so sein
das darf nicht so sein muss aber schon
auch dazu sagen weil ich mit sehr vielen
deutschen politikern zu tun
aber das sind wirklich ausnahmen
allerdings schaden diese ausnahmen
vernichten tierhäute angeschafft die
aktuellen umfragen baden württemberg und
rheinland pfalz also in beiden ländern
hat die cdu einen massiven einbruch und
das ist unserer tagesstätte cdu unrecht
weil das war nicht die cdu
baden-württemberg oder rheinland-pfalz
das waren einzelfälle anderswo her
trotzdem es gab auch wie gesagt es gab
im sommer den fall am tor wo auch schon
viel darüber diskutiert worden wurde es
gab auch aufregung über den
bundesgesundheitsminister der einen
abendessen hatte mit mehreren leuten wo
er dann spenden gesammelt hat die gerade
unter der zehn tausender grenze wo
spenden meldepflichtig sind sind also
wohl spenden gesammelt hat vom igh ist
es dann doch unions problem vor allen
dingen auch wenn man es schaut bei den
einkünften aus nebentätigkeiten für die
cdu ganz klar weit vorne die haben
verdienen das meiste neben ihrem
abgeordneten auch weil das fällt schon
auf dass das doch das fällt schon auf
dass es in der union
da häufen sich die fälle also das kann
man glaube ich dich von der hand weisen
also ich gebe ich bin auch oft mit
abgeordneten in kontakt und ich glaube
auch die allergrößte mehrheit ist also
wirklich die reifen sich auch für ihre
wahlkreise aber dass jemand an einen
berufs also quasi politik politiker
seien als nebenberuf quasi versteht und
noch geld dafür nimmt dass er seine
kontakte finde ich auch völlig normal
dass man mit seinem wahlkreis gut
verbunden ist das ist natürlich eine
haltung die schon jetzt entschuldigung
im laufe dieser letzten monate in der
union vor allem zu finden war
das ist nicht von der hand zu weisen ist
beispiel die und die
mecklenburg-vorpommersche cdu setzt dann
herrn am turnplatz 1 ja also das sind
einfach so halbwegs fragen da kann man
sich jetzt irgendwie kodex ausdenken
finde ich prima aber das muss kein
gesetz geregelt ist gespür dafür dass
gespielt das hat beim spanier auch
gefährlich also muss ich morgens bei den
kollegen vom zdf
hinzustellen zu sagen kontakt meiden
beiden meiden und abends mit zehn leuten
ein licht gesetz das abendessen zu
spenden für den kreisverband zu
veranstalten
das würde ich vielleicht einem
abgeordneten autos gehen lassen aber
nicht im gesundheitsminister der wohnung
ist was dann daraus folgen wir sagen
philipp am tor wird ge kommt auf platz
eins der liste in mecklenburg vorpommern
erspart verlangt oder frack und bittet
um spenden gerade unter der 10.000 euro
grenze die jetzt abgesenkt werden soll
was wäre denn dann die richtige
konsequenz die richtige konsequenz ist
dass generell zu sanktionieren zu sagen
jede spende muss offengelegt werden also
das kann man über die höhe streiten weil
das auch ein bürokratischer aufwand ist
er dann bei 100 euro
einfach zu hoch wäre aber es ist jetzt
von den grünen vorgeschlagen wurden 5000
es wird sich irgendwo dazwischen
einpendeln und ich denke aber dass eine
muss man von dem anderen trennen man
muss doch ein politisches gespür dafür
haben egal wie hoch jetzt die anzeigt
bahre höhe von spenden ist ob ich das in
einer situation und einer position mache
wo ich der gesundheitsminister wenn wo
ich von diesem land opfer fordere ohne
ende und dann das so machen das ist
eigentlich für mich das was ich nicht
verstehe auch bei spar vorschläge der
kluger kopf ist und auch eine große
chance hatte aber ich glaube herzlich in
dieser krise einiges vermasselt aber
gespürt kann man schlecht verordnen in
der in dem brief den die
fraktionsvorsitzenden brinkhaus und
dobrindt als chef der landesgruppe
geschrieben haben steht ich zitiere
haltung anstand und integrität sind
unverzichtbare voraussetzungen für die
tätigkeit als bundestagsabgeordneter
herr radke was wäre denn für ihre
meinung nach eine richtige konsequenz
auch wenn man noch mal den fall am tor
anschaut wenn man noch mal das verhalten
von herrn sparen mit einbezieht
ich meine klar es wird natürlich jetzt
alles alles in einen topf geworfen
ich habe schon dafür bei allem hang
verständlichen hagen jetzt alles alles
gleich abzuhandeln
da auch zu differenzieren aber genau die
stellen die richtige frage was ist jetzt
die notwendige konsequenz wenn man sieht
die cdu landtagsfraktion in nordrhein
westfalen hat heute beispielsweise auch
ihrer fraktionssitzung so habe ich
vorhin von kollegen vernommen
an einen verhaltenskodex auch
verabschiedet ich glaube das ist ein
wichtiger punkt dass wir unabhängig von
der frage was ist gesetzlich in ordnung
was ist gesetzlich nicht in ordnung
jetzt die nächsten wochen dazu nutzen um
deutlich zu machen was ist unsere
erwartungshaltung an abgeordnete von cdu
und csu dass wir aber auch die chance
nutzen zu sagen was erwarten wir in
zukunft auch von von menschen die sich
für die unionsparteien und mandate
bewerben so dass wir sozusagen auch im
im aufstellungsverfahren schon deutlich
und klar machen was unsere unsere
erwartungshaltung da als cdu ist das
wäre es könnte ein wichtiger punkt punkt
seien in den nächsten wochen
was wäre denn was wäre denn dann genau
ihre erwartungen heißt das dann zum
beispiel keine nebentätigkeiten wäre das
eine richtige konsequenz also ich halte
nichts davon generell sagen eine eine
berufstätigkeit neben dem mandat kommt
nicht kommt nicht in frage
ich halte nichts von dieser generellen
kriminalisierung warum soll jemand
seinen bauernhof verkaufen warum soll
jemand seine anwaltskanzlei schließen
weil er für vier jahre ich bin für fünf
jahre gewählt in ein parlament gewählt
wird das ist eine wichtige ehrenvolle
aufgabe ich über auch keine tätigkeiten
neben ein mandat aus ich weiß aber aus
eigenem erleben politik ist macht auf
zeit ich kenne viele die ungewollt nach
einer periode aus dem parlament
ausgeschieden sind die danach
schwierigkeiten hatten in ihren alten
beruf zurück zu kommen ich habe selber
die erfahrung gemacht ich habe mich um
ein mandat und worden es hat im ersten
nicht geklappt ich weiß wie viel hohn
und spott man auch im beruf ertragen
muss und von daher diese mehr einmal
gewählt und dann
eine vollversorgung bis ans lebensende
das einfach quatsch also eine generelle
kriminalisierung und verbot von von
beruflicher tätigkeiten dem man da darf
es nicht geben es muss aber klar sein es
darf keine verbindung geben ich mache
mal ein konkretes beispiel
es kann nicht sein dass sich nebenbei
noch bei einem energiekonzern
beschäftigt bin und gleichzeitig im
wirtschaftsausschuss die
energiepolitische gesetzgebung mache das
kann und darf es nicht geben da muss man
in zukunft noch klarer und deutlicher
sein aber ein generelles verbot davon
halte ich nichts aber die regeln müssen
klar erkennbaren und nachvollziehbar
sein und zwar nicht nur fraktionsintern
sondern auch für die bürgerinnen und
bürger ok yoga ich glaube sie wollten
aber seit dem thema nebentätigkeit sagen
ja ich wollte ihr wollt zwei dinge
gesagt haben ich sitz hier nicht als
verteidiger der cdu csu sondern als
freiberufler aber trotzdem so
darzustellen als wer also die spd
blitzsauber und alle haben dann auch
blitzsauber und böse sie ist nur die
union das ist einfach falsch sorry
vermehrt dass das verdreht die sachlage
zweiter punkt politik und abgeordneter
ist kein hauptberuf und tat kein
hauptberuf seien bei den sitzen
plötzlich nur mehr lehrer beamte und
partei angestellte im parlament das wäre
völlig verrückt wir brauchen damen und
herren in den parlamenten die aus der
realwelt kommen das heißt einem realen
beruf haben was es fehlt und wo man viel
strenger sein könnte um viel strenger
sein müsste ist die registrierung der
tätigkeit die abgeordnete männlich oder
weiblich ausüben und wie weit hier eine
verbindung gibt das beispiel mit rwe
also jemand der hauptberuflich bei der
rwe es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so ganz
in den energieausschuss hineinpassen
das gehört genau dokumentiert gesagt
dass nicht den politikern den beruf
verbieten bei niederrad gerichtet sagte
irgendwann muss er ja in den beruf
zurück wir wollen ja auch keine ewigen
abgeordneten die 40 1 bundestag sitzen
aber es muss klar sein und zwar für den
nachvollziehbar was treibt und woher
kommt das geld das er neben dem
abgeordnetenmandat bedient und für diese
transparenz gibt es unter anderem ja
demnächst ein lobbyregister frau meier
das ist noch in der entwicklung oder
soll jetzt ja noch soll jetzt
verabschiedet werden da gab es ein
simples hin und her auch klassischen spd
und cdu da wollte die spd gerne
weitergehen dass man schaut zum beispiel
vor einem gesetzentwurf welchen einfluss
hatten da stimmte wer hat noch eben
gesprochen
genau wie sinnvoll ist dass und wie wird
sich das jetzt entwickeln durch diese
affäre die wir im moment haben
naja ich halte das schon für sinnvoll
also ich verstehe schon dass es
irgendwie manchmal gespräche gibt denen
ich jeden etwas angehen aber es ist nun
mal sind volksvertreter innen und die
sollten auch transparent arbeiten im
sinne derjenigen die sie gewählt haben
und es ist tatsächlich zwischen spd und
cdu also in der regierungskoalition
strittig und war auch deutlich zu spüren
dass die spd mehr will ich würde auch
gerne dazu noch mal was sagen das ist
nicht so dass ich finde dass die spd
total toll ist und die die cdu oder die
cs oder irgendwie mal an sich arbeiten
sollte aber es bleibe dabei es ist schon
auffällig in letzter zeit da werden sie
mir schon recht geben herr yoga oder
also ich habe jetzt nichts gehört aus
der spd vielleicht werden wir in den
nächsten tagen noch was aus der spd das
ist gut möglich denn es soll ja jetzt
noch mehr dran
gemeinsam mit geschichts studien machen
nur fabrik mit dem lobbyregister lösen
es ja nicht das problem der politiker er
weder der fall am tor noch die zwei
aktuellen fälle würden geregelt werden
durch ein lobbyregister das stimmt
amerikaner verpflichtet sich zu
registrieren als politiker also dass man
meint dass lobbyregister schützt uns vor
kriminellen abgeordneten das ist
wirklich eine illusion
trotz steuerpflicht erberich ist da habe
ich auch in ihrer sendung sei aber
wissen wir ja alles nicht das problem
ist dass wir im moment haben ja aber
trotzdem geht es ja grundsätzlich auch
um einen vertrauensverlust in politik
und wird dann heißt also für den
normalen bürger der sagt dann na ja das
wird alles hier
einander gemauschelt und dagegen wir
brauchen mehr transparenz sagt die
andere walter schmidinger wie wichtig
ist dass man sagt wir müssen schauen
dass wir das miteinander von politik von
wirtschaft eben transparenter machen und
wie sehr hilft da so ein lockeres das
hilft absoluter bin ich bei formayer ich
bin selber mitglied im beirat der
deutschen gesellschaft für
politikberatung wir fordern das seit
2009 dass dieses lobbyregister kommt und
das ist hart und deutlich wird und was
herr juncker gesagt hat stimmt ja die
abgeordneten sind eigentlich die
empfänger der lobbytätigkeit oder
diejenigen die angesprochen werden
ob sie die anliegen die da vorgetragen
werden richtig finden müssen sie selber
entscheiden aber das lobby register ist
ja dazu da deutlich zu machen wer
versucht diese abgeordneten oder eben
die regierung und das ist der nächste
punkt auch die regierung müsste ja in
diese slogans mit einbezogen werden
nicht nur der bundestag das muss dann
deutlich gemacht wird und dann ist es
transparent aber die kriege hat sich da
hätte ich auch gegen das wird sich jetzt
nicht mehr torwart widersprechen sie mir
aber ich glaube das kann sich kein
fraktionsvorsitzender mehr leisten das
zu blockieren und auch keine fraktionen
die jetzt diese erfahrung gemacht hat
der rat gestern ist das ein instrument
um mehr vertrauen wieder zu schaffen
also wir haben ja hier auf der
europäischen ebene ein lobbyregister wir
haben ja auch in parlamenten
entsprechenden verhaltenskodex
ich habe immer also ich bin nicht gegen
ein solches lobbyregister ich glaube
auch das brauchen wir jetzt ganz schnell
als vertrauensbildende maßnahme man muss
nur sehen was macht sinn
und was macht keinen sinn es ist
geradezu recht beschrieben worden
diese beiden fälle werden durch ein
lobbyregister nicht gelöst worden weil
hier geht es am ende nicht um eine
systemfrage sondern bei diesen beiden
fällen geht es um die charakterfrage und
charakterliche defizite und die können
sie mit keinem mit keinem register und
mit mit keiner transparenzrichtlinie
ausbügeln oder oder gerade wegen aber
nichtsdestotrotz dem wenn da jetzt nicht
darum herumkommen finden wir haben hier
auf der europäischen ebene damit auch
gute erfahrungen gemacht nur den satz
will ich ab
noch mal sagen hier haben wir auch immer
wieder in der diskussion mit den grünen
die sagen das geht noch alles nicht weit
genug wir müssen alles transparent
machen jedes gespräch muss transparent
gemacht werden und da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen dazu bin ich nicht bereit
das schränkt die freiheit des mandates 1
ich fühle hier auch wichtige
vertrauliche gespräche mit betriebsräten
mit unternehmensvertretern wo es um
massive probleme in unternehmen geht und
da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen das geht
niemanden etwas an
das muss auch vertraulich behandelt
werden können
ansonsten ist für mich auch die die
freiheit des mandates gefährdet aber da
gibt es nicht nur schwarz oder weiß
sondern eine ganze menge bei graustufen
dazwischen und ich bin ganz sicher
werden jetzt in den nächsten wochen auch
innerhalb dieser graustufen zu einer
lösung am thema mobile dienstag kommen
da kommen wir gar nicht mehr und man
könnte ja sagen man kann verstehen dass
die inhalte vertraulich sind aber warum
ist es nicht gut zu sagen mit wem man
spricht dabei entschuldigen sie mal wenn
mir ob obst betriebsräte sind oder oder
gewerkschaftsvertreter oder
unternehmensvertreter zu einer zu einer
krise die noch gar nicht öffentlich ist
mit mir gespräche führen wollen warum
soll ich das öffentlich machen sagen sie
mir doch einfach mal wo der mehrwert da
ist also neben purem voyeurismus oder
neugierig wo ist da der mehrwert ja
damit ich verstehe wie politik
funktioniert damit ich da mehr vertrauen
habe herr jurga was sagen sie denn als
lobbyist es ist sinnvoll dass man dass
man weiß also da muss ich also ich
möchte mir ein spirituell recht geben
und biete dem herrn abgeordneten radke
wieder sprechen zu dürfen
ich bin auch in der deutschen
gesellschaft für politikberatung und
idee gebiet seit 2009 das
verpflichtendes lobbyregister das gibt
es in brüssel das gibt es in paris das
ist zu greifen ist anträge registriert
in brüssel ich bin registriert in paris
mit registriert in wen ich würde mich
mit begeisterung auch in berlin
registrieren und selbstverständlich
bekanntgeben wie es nämlich rede und
wofür ich rede das gehört in der lobby
register hinein was
nicht hineingehört dass sich aber herr
jörg adami meine frau hasst hat das team
zeit das neue idee ist da natürlich
fahrrad gesehen wollte eine frage
stellen also hat das ab ja genau hat das
lobby register in wien verhindert dass
der damalige österreichische vizekanzler
bereit war auf ibiza sein halbes land zu
versteuern hat dass das lobbyregister
verhindert ja er ist ein krimineller
politiker ja dann legen sie bitte
falscher weil die register hätte weder
das haben sie sogar selber gesagt werden
das hätte jeder geregelten arretieren
berliner noch den fall thema in wien mit
dem herrn strache hatten
wer der herr strache als amtierender
vize kanzler natürlich nicht ins
lobbyregister als lobbyist eingetragen
worden wäre
versuch madoff bietet zu trennen es gibt
die politik ob die politischen
entscheidungsträger und die sind im saal
des bundestages und es gibt die
lobbyisten die sie in dem vorraum
finanzlobby und das kann ich nicht lösen
indem es in einen topf
trotzdem er hat was nicht stört ja auch
da denke ich mich mit dem herrn schmidt
duell ist dass die jetzige debatte in
berlin verkauft weil sie viel zu viele
ausnahmen beinhaltet
wenn ich also zum beispiel hinein
schreibe rechtsanwälte sind ausgenommen
das steht also in dem derzeitigen
einigungs passiert drinnen
naja es findet dann jeder interessierte
einen anwalt der seinen namen her gibt
dafür bei prozent vom irakkrieg und der
lobby vorgang geschickt die lobby
register und der mann es ist umso eher
noch wenn man jetzt natürlich entweder
ganze prozess der interessensvertreter
und himmel
ja ich würde ganz gerne mal auf die sich
der der wähler und der bürger dar
einbringen denn auch wenn man sozusagen
für die politik profis die sie hier alle
sind sagt ja man kann das alles nicht
vermengen die außenwirkung des gesamten
politikbetriebes ist er einfach dann
verheerend frau meier wie schafft man es
jetzt wieder an vertrauen da rein zu
bekommen also auch für die
mehrheit der abgeordneten die redlich
ist jetzt ist die frage zum beispiel die
abgeordneten sollen das geld spenden
würde so etwas überhaupt helfen
na ja ich würde erstmal helfen das denke
ich schon also das ist eine honorige
forderungen die im krassen widerspruch
zu dem steht was vorgefallen ist
insofern wäre das erste mal dass das
etwas nivellieren ich wie man vertrauen
wieder herstellen kann ist glaube ich
die ganz große frage jetzt also ich
finde es eigentlich ganz gut was herr
abgemacht dass man sich sozusagen auch
mit breiter brust ins stellt und sagt es
tut uns leid und wir werden es ändern
was aber als zum beispiel nicht aus
meiner sicht dazu beiträgt ist wenn man
immer sagt charakter und einzelfall
das ist es fällt es tut mir leid aber es
fällt doch schon auf das ist irgendwie
mehr geworden ist und das ist in der
letzten zeit das eben zum beispiel
jemand wie herr amthor den spitz die
spitzenkandidatur in seinem
landesverband bekommen hat deshalb keine
konsequenzen
und wenn man in einer partei oder
fraktion ist die immer sagt ach mit
diesem lobbyregister das machen wir
jetzt noch nicht oder wir machen es nur
so halb das ist quasi ein ansporn an die
politikerinnen und politiker wirklich
also dann nicht wenn ihr da schon eine
sekunde noch charakter
ich finde da muss es ein gesetz geben
kein kodex das muss rechtlich geregelt
werden und wer der gesetzgeber der
bundestag dem musters regeln also müsste
ja auch genommen dazu die wollten
widersprechen
ja also ja was heißt widersprechen also
ich meine freundin frau meier erkennbare
lust an dem fall philipp amt hat sie
haben es jetzt zum dritten mal aber so
zu tun als sei überhaupt keinen preis
überhaupt keinen preis bezahlt worden
ist ja in der sache nicht richtig weil
wir für den fehler den er gemacht hat
hat er am ende damit bezahlt dass er
erstens nicht spitzenkandidat zur
landtagswahl geworden ist und zweitens
auch nicht cdu landesvorsitzender haben
also nichts sagen so zu tun als wäre man
hier wird aber er das ist glaube ich das
ist aber wenn es immer so dargestellt
wird es es sei kein preis bezahlt worden
ist allergie bezahlt worden
dann ist das einfach in der sache falsch
da widerspreche ich er hat zwar auf zwei
positionen verzichten müssen
aber die spitzenkandidat zur
bundestagswahl suggeriert doch dem
bürger den wahl volk das ist jetzt
vergessen
das ist jetzt vorbei jetzt macht er so
weiter wie vorher ich will nicht
behaupten dass er das tut aber das ist
ein fatales zeichen nicht gelernt zu
haben und das ist das glaube ich was von
meyer eben meinte dass die politik
natürlich wenn sie nicht sanktioniert
was passiert ist dass sie dann auch
nicht mehr glaubwürdig ist und kann ich
beurteilen wie mecklenburg vorpommern
bei der bundestagswahl entscheidet und
ob das den ausschlag gibt bei der cdu
aber für die grund- sauberkeit einer
partei wäre es angemessen gewesen dass
er auf diese position verzichtete der
kann in seinem wahlkreis antreten und
gewählt werden
als direkt gewählter abgeordneter der ja
ist wird er das wahrscheinlich wieder
schaffen
aber wenn ich das ernst nehmen mit dem
saubermachen mit den regeln schaffen
dann gehört er nicht an die
spitzenposition und sie kennen sich aus
mit krisenkommunikation das haben sie
auch schon gemacht ist das ein punkt wo
sagen sie wo muss man da jetzt ansetzen
also ich glaube ich glaube eher das
brinkhaus und dobrindt das richtig
gemacht haben ich glaube mit der
brachialen forderung die da ist und auch
laschet heute jeder abgeordnete der was
er nicht was gemacht hat soll sich bei
ihm persönlich melden
ob sie das tun ist was anderes das ist
absolut richtig und ich finde auch die
forderung der csu richtig dass die das
spenden müssen beide weder klein noch
löwe haben ja bisher die sache sozusagen
bedauert sie haben gesagt es war
rechtens
bislang weist alle vorwürfe zurück es
ist kein satz des bedauerns es ist kein
satz des nachempfinden was die
bevölkerung hier davon denkt gekommen
und das was vor mir sagte spenden und
die csu fordert dass spenden dieser
einnahmen an eine gemeinnützige
organisation oder an ein krankenhaus das
seine pflege kräfte davon besser bezahlt
das wäre dann auch das deutlicher
eingeständnis dass man an
unrechtsbewusstsein hat und das vermisse
ich bei diesen beiden das kann man aber
wahrscheinlich ja auch nicht verordnen
um sie dann
die beiden die beiden herren unter
beweis gestellt dass ganz offensichtlich
der der charakterliche hirntod
eingetreten ist und von daher habe ich
auch keine hoffnung dass da irgendwas
gespendet wird aber immer das
abgeordnetengesetz ist da alles ja klar
wenn sie durch ihr abgeordnetenmandat
die also diese einnahmen generiert haben
auf unrechtmäßigen wege dann sind diese
mittel an die dem bundeshaushalt
zuzuführen und da bin ich mal gespannt
inwieweit man sich jetzt darum eine
entsprechende vollstreckung auch bemüht
er rate ich bin nur etwas wenn sie so
klar sagen charakterliche hirntot ist ja
schon sehr stark wenn er hennes land ist
seit 20 jahren im bundestag dann fragt
man sich ja schon wie kommt das er ist
stellvertretender fraktions vize er hat
ein hohes amt gut aber wussten wussten
sie bis die fälle öffentlich geworden
sind dass das solche sollten solche
dinge vorsicht also das kann doch das
kann doch niemand an und ich meine das
hatte auch ralph brinkhaus gestern
gesagt wenn sie ihn vor zwei wochen auch
sowas angesprochen er gesagt das ist das
ist für mich undenkbar und ich meine der
charakterliche hirntod bezog sich bezog
sich ja darauf was was die kollegen
gemacht haben was sie angerichtet haben
also ich meine wer so etwas tut der kann
ja wirklich nicht mehr ganz bei sinnen
sein der hat jegliche antenne jeglichen
kontakt zur wirklichkeit verloren
wir haben frage ist nur wie so was
entstehen kann wie man als abgeordneter
jeglichen kontakt zur wirklichkeit
verlieren kann
heyo k sie wollten da noch zwei mal
recht geben mit dem herrn schmid jo
schmid aktuell dass ich finde das was
gestern von der fraktionsspitze cdu/csu
kam war richtig war auch in der
deutlichkeit richtig gleiches gilt für
der erklärung des parteivorsitzenden
laschet und ich gebe jetzt ausdrücklich
auch der frau meier recht was sie zu
amthor gesagt hat nicht alles in der
politik was juristisch korrekt ist in
ordnung da am tor hat also jetzt in
china auf
an die spitze in mecklenburg vorpommern
gerechtfertigt dass er gesagt hat
juristisch konnte man ihm nichts
nachweisen alle untersuchungen
eingestellt das mag sein das ist auch
nicht die aufgabe der politischen
debatte dafür haben wir staatsanwälte
aber politisch war das was er macht den
leicht in ordnung und da jetzt sofort
den weg zur spitze zurückzukriegen finde
ich auch als alter schwarzer nicht okay
hätte man nicht tun sollen
das interessante das ist für mich schon
auch wenn bemerkenswerte frage wie lange
politische geschichte des herrn müssen
wo man sich fragt also hat er das
wirklich zum ersten mal gemacht oder
machte der sowas schon früher
und warum ist es in ist es niemand
aufgefallen dass man natürlich wieder
bei der frage wie werden
nebenbeschäftigungen angegeben wie
werden dem beschäftigungen registriert
und wer in einer fraktion überprüft dass
das geht auch bitte für alle fraktionen
um nicht nur für die schwarzen da
brauchen wir einen anderen mechanismus
krise nur den kreis zuvor hing gestern
mechanismus ist nicht das lobbys da
braucht man ein anderes gesetz oder
schärfere vorgaben
ich würde ganz gerne in die letzten
minuten nutzen um mal zu gucken was das
jetzt auch für die union bedeuten kann
vielleicht auch für die anderen parteien
frau meier wir haben ein wahljahr kann
das noch so harte konsequenzen haben sie
haben es doch in einem kommentar im
weser-kurier geblieben dass die cdu
letztendlich ja dass der weg ins
kanzleramt schwieriger werden könnte
dadurch ja also der preis kann hoch sein
also es kann ist möglich dass die cdu
tatsächlich diese oder die union den
sich die sicher geglaubte kanzlerschaft
dadurch mindestens gefährdet würde ich
sagen also wenn die opposition schlau
ist und das ist sie ist nicht jedenfalls
nicht dumm wird sie wird sie das nutzen
diese vorlage das ist auch einfach zu
schön aber was es gibt auch ist weil er
sich einen funken hoffnung es gibt
nämlich ein ziemlich neuen
parteivorsitzenden und der auch schon
hat anklingen lassen wo es unter ihm
mit ihm lang geht und das ist erstmal
kommunikativ ziemlich gut was ich da
sehe muss ich sagen also ich traue armin
laschet zu auch wenn er in dieser ich
sag nur van laak da gibt es ja auch
wieder geschichten aber er ist noch jung
so bringt er kann gehen aber da gab es
ja darum die mannschaft vor die massen
bescheidenen nrw aber da ging natürlich
um geld da ging es nicht um geld
genommen aber es ist ein neuer
parteivorsitzender der kann jetzt
irgendwie eine gute richtung vorgeben
was er jetzt gezeigt hat hat er schon
ist finde ich kann die partei
hoffnungsvoll stimmen aber jetzt muss
ich natürlich auch wirklich konsequenzen
folgen also das muss sichtbar sein
das ist ein großes risiko für die union
oder vielleicht gerade noch mal eine
besondere chance wenn sie jetzt so ganz
deutlich sagt dass sie da härtere
konsequenzen wenn nicht bekommt wenn
nichts mehr kommt wird es keine weiteren
fälle gibt dann kann es eine chance sein
es wird aber erst mal im keller gehen
wir haben ja dieser woche
forschungsgruppe wahlen infratest dimap
gehabt cdu verliert in beiden ländern wo
am sonntag gewählt wird und sie lädt im
bund und der nachlauf der stimmung der
setzt ja erst noch ein
die erfahrung zeigte aus der ganzen
geschichte der umfragen dass das erst
später kommen das wird in vier wochen
kommen dann wird die stimmung nochmal
für die union im keller gehen und dann
wird die entscheidende frage sein wer
wird der kanzlerkandidat wer ist der
überzeugende der sowohl diese krise
diese corona krise aber auch diese
politische krise die wir im moment haben
managen kann
und ich denke damit wird es werden oder
werden müssen das ist seine einzige
chance und wenn man von meier zu er
wächst da gerade irgendwo eine aufgabe
rein nachdem er lange zeit mehr anders
ist und das kann dann für ihn schon zu
sein ja herr radke wie sehen sie sind da
näher dran sind im landesvorstand nrw
wie stark spüren sie da entweder die
angst dass es schiefgehen könnte oder
gerade jetzt eine besondere energie dass
man sagt jetzt müssen wir ja noch mal
besonders zeigen wo wir stehen ja beides
also ich glaube dass die situation
bedrohlich ist das kann man da auch gar
nicht wegdiskutieren
wir haben heute aber ausführlich über
den über den vertrauensschaden
diskutiert und es wird jetzt ganz
entscheidend darauf ankommen wie gehen
wir jetzt damit um und ich teile die
zuversicht mit blick auf armin laschet
und ich habe die situation ja 2012
erlebt da war die cdu in nordrhein
westfalen am boden nicht wegen
persönlicher verfehlungen einzelner
abgeordneter sondern ist ist alles
bekannt das desaströse ergebnis 2012
diese landespartei lag am boden und
armin laschet hat diese landespartei
wieder aufgerichtet hat ein starkes team
gebildet und hat sie was fast niemand
erwartet hat fünf jahre später in die
regierung geführt in nordrhein-westfalen
und deswegen armin laschet hat erfahrung
damit
mit schwierigen situationen umzugehen
ich bin sicher er wird die flucht nach
vorn antreten wird dafür sorgen dass
hier jetzt aufgeräumt wird und wird auch
dafür sorgen dass mindestens genauso
wichtig dass wir in den nächsten wochen
nicht nur über dieses thema reden
sondern dass wir auch darüber reden mit
welcher mannschaft mit welchem programm
wollen wir in den wahlkampf gehen und
wollen wir die zukunft dieses landes
anpacken dann kann die opposition das ja
dann wunderbar nutzen um immer wieder
auf in diese wunde rhein zu bohren so zu
sagen herr jurga sie reden mit vielen
abgeordneten haben sie das gefühl dass
auch in anderen parteien da die angst
umgeht dass dann noch mehr für das da
auch fälle in anderen parteien aufkommen
es wäre anmerkungen dazu
das eine was ich nicht verstehe es nicht
meine aufgabe die sozialdemokratie zu
beraten aber am höhepunkt einer
derartigen krise der cdu csu sich in
eine in der schlacht um äußerungen des
herrn thierse unter frau gesine schwan
zu stürzen die eigentlich außerhalb der
funktionäre und bei amtsträgern der spd
keiner versteht ist mir unbegreiflich
also warum die spd jetzt im moment nicht
wirklich einmal was leistet ist
erstaunlich zweite bemerkung vor einer
woche um die zeit hätte ich gesagt das
ist keine frage der nächste
bundeskanzler deutschlands ist ein mann
und kommt aus der union
zum thema mal welcher der unions
kandidaten sich durchsetzen es gibt
deren genug ich würde heute nicht mehr
unter garantie sagen dass der nächste
bundeskanzler deutschlands männlich ist
es könnte auch eine frau werden wenn die
grünen die vorburg aufstellen und es ist
noch nicht mehr gesagt dass die cdu/csu
vorne ist so sind das irgendwie habe ich
aber nicht erkennen dass die
sozialdemokratie was draus macht ja die
frage ist wie arbeitet man es auf und
das haben sie richtig gefragt tabletten
sind das zwei einzelfälle oder dort noch
was andere ist auch wenn doch was
anderes auftaucht dann hat die cdu/csu
wirklich ein großes problem da auch
nichts anderes mehr auf dann wird ein
gewisses maß vergessen bis september
antreten aber so triumphal wie es noch
vor zwei drei wochen für die cdu in
richtung september ausgesehen hat sie es
nicht mehr aus das ist wahr das war ein
harter schlag ins kontor wie er will und
wir haben ja auch alle noch ein anderes
thema was uns die ganze zeit beschäftigt
das ist nunmal corona und darüber reden
wir auch morgen ihnen herzlichen dank
für diese diskussion und morgen geht es
mal wieder um das thema corona wo auch
viele inzwischen unzufrieden sind wir
fragen deutschlands corona management
gut gemeint schlecht organisiert dann
ist mein kollege alexander kähler für
sie die ihnen einen schönen abend und
jetzt geht es weiter mit phoenix der tag
bis dann
[Musik]